So, Meeting einverstanden.
Guten Abend.
Guten Abend Herr Doktor, hallo.
Ich bin heute der Diensthabender Arzt auf dieser Stelle
und würde gerne mit Ihnen den Aufnahmischsprach durchführen.
Zuerst würde ich Ihnen ein paar Fragen, ein paar persönliche Fragen stellen.
Danach kommen wir zu den Beschwerden, zu Eure Beschwerden.
Zuerst würde ich Ihnen Ihre Name fragen.
Zu Ihren Beschwerden.
Wie heißen Sie?
Mein Name ist Dietrich Spies.
Dietrich Spies?
Mein schwieriger Name können Sie stabilieren.
Ja, natürlich.
Spies ist Siegfried Paola.
Dietrich Spies.
Dietrich ist der Vorname.
Dorahid Emil Theodor.
Dietrich Spies.
Wie alt sind Sie?
Ich bin 84 Jahre alt.
84. Kann ich Ihnen fragen, wann genau Sie geboren sind?
Ich bin am 23.05.
1909.
Was ist das?
39.
68, 24.
38, 39.
Wie schwer sind Sie?
Wie viel wiegen Sie?
Ich wiege 79 kg.
Und wie groß sind Sie?
1,83 m.
80.
Wo wohnen Sie?
Ich wohne in Hamburg, in der Sahne.
Was sind Sie auf Beruf?
Von Beruf.
Ich bin Kaufmann gewesen.
Seit meinem 65. Lebensjahr bin ich in Rente.
Seit 30 Jahren.
Seit 20 Jahren.
Kann ich Ihre Hausarzt fragen?
Nach meinem Hausarzt?
Sie wollen den Namen vom Hausarzt wissen?
Ja, der Name ist für uns vielleicht.
Der Name, genau.
Das ist Dr. Müller.
In der Hauptstraße 25.
Sind Sie verheiratet?
Ja, ich bin verheiratet.
Ich lebe noch mit meiner Frau zusammen.
Ich habe 2 Kinder.
Das war es für die Personen.
Jetzt kommen wir zu den Beschwerden.
Was führt Sie zu uns?
Herr Dr. Müller.
Ich habe seit 20 Jahren.
Ich habe seit einem halben Jahr schon zunehmende Luftnoten.
Ich fühle mich schwach.
Das ist in den letzten 2 Wochen schlimmer geworden.
Bei der geringsten Belastung.
Bei der Gartenarbeit.
Wenn ich treppen steige, muss ich kurz stehen.
Nach Luft schnappen.
Das fällt mir schwerer.
Das war vorher nicht davon.
Was kann ich sagen?
Haben Sie mit diesem Atemnot noch irgendwelche Beschwerden?
Neben diesem Atemnot?
Ich bin sehr müde.
Ich bin sehr schlapp und kraftlos.
Was mir auch fehlt,
ist, dass ich wahnsinnig Wasser einladen kann.
Ich habe noch keine Schmerzen.
Ich darf meist auf album적인 Alleine halten.
Tu diese Erfahrungen.
Ich muss etwas Wasser lassen?
Klar.
Herzrasen?
Na gr hardships.
9 Wochen haben Sie irgendjemand Herztbesucht?
Das war erstmal.
Mein Arzt ist in Urlaub und zu der Vertretung wollte ich nicht hingehen und deswegen bin
direkt zu ihnen gekommen.
Ja, sie lagen Wasser.
Keine Frage, keine Frage.
Das ist mein erster Mal, diese Handschutte.
Haben sie irgendwelche...
Sie waren so ein Druck auf den Brust oder ein...
Hast du so ein Engelgefühl auf dem Brust?
Nein, das kenne ich von meinen Nachbarn.
Der hatte mal einen Herzinfarkten, der hatte so beschrieben, dass er so ein Druck hatte.
Nein, das habe ich nicht, glücklicherweise.
Also ich habe kein Druck oder kein Engelgefühl, ich habe wirklich nur Luftnot.
Nun noch Luftnot haben sie und...
Was soll ich noch fragen?
Ich bin lustig, weil ich nicht glaube.
Warum? Meinst du nicht? Spreng sie mal.
Also mein Hauptsymptom ist, dass ich schwach bin und dass ich Luftnot habe.
Ja, dann...
Herzraten haben sie nicht.
Sind Sie ein bisschen aufgeregt, Herr Doktor?
Ja, ich bin ein bisschen aufgeregt.
Ich bin ein bisschen aufgeregt.
Okay, das kann ich noch machen.
Es kommt nichts. Ich ist erst auf die Luft.
Genau.
Also wie gesagt, und ich finde, dass viele Wasser in den Beinen.
Das ist so mein anderes Problem.
Was glauben Sie, was es sein könnte, Herr Doktor?
Es kann eine Herzinsuffizienz sein.
Mein Herr dachte es drauf.
Was heißt das Herzinsuffizienz? Was muss ich darunter verstehen?
Ich habe das Herz wegen diesem langen Zeit, lebenszeit müde geworden.
Und kann noch nicht mehr drücken.
Ich glaube...
Was ist das Herzschwachpunkt?
Ja.
Das ist meine Herzschwache.
Das ist das Herzschwach geworden ist.
Ah, okay.
Was haben Sie in Infektionen gehabt, bevor diese Beschwerden auftreten?
Nein, Infektionen hatte ich jetzt nicht.
Es war alles ganz gut in den letzten Jahren.
Ist mir nicht aufgefallen.
Als die Märzien oder irgendwer Grieppe nehmen?
Nein.
Nehmen Sie irgendwelche Medikamente?
Ja, ich habe einige Medikamente für den Blutdruck.
Und das hat alles mein Hausarzt geregelt.
Das ist auch, glaube ich, etwas für den Cholesterin dabei.
Sie haben den Hypertonian, hohes Blutdruck,
krankeitig glaube ich, und Cholesterinerhöhung.
Ja, genau.
Seit wann haben Sie diese?
Das geht schon über 20 Jahre, noch länger.
Seit 20 Jahren nehmen Sie Medikamente für Blutdruck.
Ich nehme die Medikamente.
Welche Medikamente nehmen Sie ein?
Das heißt Bellopzock.
Eine morgens, eine abends.
Amlodipin, eine Tablette morgens.
Und dann noch Kandesatan, 8 mg am Abend.
Ich habe dann noch Ass 100.
Und dann noch eine Tablette gegen Cholesterine.
Ich nehme diese Amlodipin seit 20 Jahren.
Oder haben Sie noch?
20 Jahre ungefähr.
Das kann auch diese Beschwerden auftreten.
Amlodipin-Nägen-Wirkungen.
Beinschwellungen dazu.
Ach so, okay, kann natürlich sein.
Aber bisher habe ich das immer ganz gut vertragen.
Ich hatte seit über 20 Jahren nie Probleme gehabt.
Okay.
Sie wissen nicht die Cholesterin-Medikamentik?
Habs verstanden, die Namen wissen Sie nicht?
Ich weiß aber den Namen nicht.
Okay.
Welche anderen haben Sie noch andere Krankheiten,
außer Blutdruck und Cholesterine?
Das ist genug, Herr Doktor, oder?
Sind Ihre Vater und Mutter noch lebendig?
Sie meinen, ob meine Eltern noch leben?
Ja, noch.
Herr Doktor, ich bin noch schon 85.
Meine Eltern sind schon seit über 30 Jahren schon verstorben.
Ja, deswegen habe ich so gefragt.
Sie haben auch einige Krankheiten, wie Sie?
Ach so, meine Eltern hatten Krankheiten.
Ja, mein Vater hatte auch hohe Blutdruck, der stimmt.
Ich weiß, dass meine Mutter hohe Cholesterine hatte.
Sie hatte auch Diabetes aber auch gehabt.
Ich glaube, Sie haben diese Krankheiten von Ihren Eltern bekommen.
Nein, das kann schon sein, der stimmt.
Kann das sein?
Haben Sie auf diesem Zeit Ihre Temperatur gemessen?
Temperatur? Nein, habe ich nicht gemessen.
Nein, aber ich fühle mich nicht warm.
Ich glaube, ich habe keine Temperatur.
Und können Sie gut schlafen oder haben Sie auch Luftnot?
Schlafen ist schwierig.
Wenn ich mich hinwege, dann wird die Luft noch schlimmer.
Ich schlafe jetzt in den letzten Tagen im Sitzen.
Das ist schwierig für Sie.
Haben Sie Ihre Appetit verloren?
Ja, so einen großen Hunger habe ich jetzt auch nicht mehr.
Ich esse schon noch ein bisschen,
aber der Appetit ist schon weniger geworden.
Das stimmt schon, ja.
Sie haben noch gesagt,
beim Wasserlassen haben Sie Schwierigkeiten.
Beim Stuhlgang haben Sie Schwierigkeiten?
Oder ist das normal?
Nein, das ist normal.
Das ist in Ordnung.
Mit Wasserlassen können Sie noch?
Ich glaube, das geht eigentlich.
Wasserlassen ist, ich muss nachts öfters mal zum Wasserlassen raus.
Ja.
Nehmen Sie Thoracemid oder Thoracemid auch ein?
Was ist das?
Das ist für diese Wassersammlung eine Medikamente für Wassersammlung.
Das macht die Ödem.
Das macht Wasserlassen mehr.
Das verstärkt das Wasserlassen.
Das ist für die Wassersammlung ein Wasser ausschwemmen, sagen Sie.
Ja.
Nein, so ein Medikament habe ich bisher noch nicht.
Haben Sie irgendwelche Stress?
Sind Sie unter Druck in den letzten Tagen?
Nein, ich bin Rentner.
Ich bin glücklich, ich habe keine Probleme.
Aber was ich vergessen habe, Herr Doktor,
die Halsvenen angucken, die sind richtig dick geworden.
Das sind so richtig hier, auf beiden Seiten.
Da sind sie richtig prall geworden, die Halsvenen.
Sind Ihre Beschwerden plötzlich aufgetreten?
Nein, die habe ich schon seit halbem Jahr so zunehmend beschwerden.
Und seit zwei Wochen ist es schlimmer geworden.
Ich möchte einige persönliche Fragen stellen,
dass wir jede Patientin stellen.
Nehmen Sie irgendwelche Drogen und rauchen Sie?
Ach Gott, nein, nein, nein, nein.
Das ist das, wie er wurde.
Wo denken Sie hin, Herr Doktor?
Die Zeiten sind vorbei.
Rauchen Sie?
Nein, schon lange nicht mehr.
Trinken Sie Alkohol?
Ja, ab und zu, aber auch nicht mehr so viel.
Ja, dann reingen Sie mit ab und zu, wochenlich?
Nein, wenn man so ein Fest ist oder bei einem Essen,
dann nehme ich mal so ein Gläschen Wein, aber ansonsten eher nicht.
Ja, gut.
Haben wir irgendwelche Allergien?
Ja, wenn Sie mich so fragen, ich hatte mal eine Reaktion
auf ein Schmerzmedikament.
Ich glaube, das hieß Nauvaldien oder so ähnlich.
Und auch ein Antibiotikum.
Das heißt, glaube ich, Zephyroxin.
Noch eine Frage über Ihre Beschwerden.
Haben Sie irgendwelche Schmerzen?
Schmerzen jetzt nicht unbedingt,
aber ab und zu habe ich so ein bisschen Rückenschmerzen
oder so Kreuzschmerzen.
Das ist ab und zu auch.
Ab und zu, wenn ich im Garten mal arbeite, aber...
Ich glaube, das war...
Ich habe keine mehr...
Ja, ist das was Schlimmes?
Nein, ich glaube, Sie haben einfach
Herzen zufizient wegen dieser Hypertonik-Bluthochdruck bekommen.
Das hätten Sie einfach bevor,
aber es ist ein bisschen schlimmer geworden.
Ich glaube, Sie brauchen noch einige Medikamente drauf.
Aber die Blutung war eigentlich immer in Ordnung?
Wir müssen es messen.
Haben Sie...
Ich habe immer regelmäßig gemessen.
Der war immer so bei 120 zu 70 oder 130 zu 80,
aber mehr war der nicht.
Ja, diese Beschwerden sind nicht wegen Bluthochdruck.
Ach so.
Ich glaube, Ihre Herz ist ein bisschen müde geworden,
die ich zuerst habe.
Sind deswegen noch Untersuchungen
oder wie wollen Sie das feststellen?
Ja, zuerst werden wir eine EKG schreiben.
Dann würden wir ein Ultraschall
auf Ihre Herz machen.
Um Herzen machen.
Um Herzen, ein Ultraschall machen.
Dann geht es weiter.
Eine Blutabnahme ist schon wichtig.
Sie wissen es.
Wenn Sie in einem Krankenhaus besuchen,
dann bekommen Sie immer ein Blutab.
Das ist auch gut so.
Dann können Sie genau sagen, woher das kommt.
Ja, ich glaube, wegen diesem Herzinsuffizienz
Herzmüdigkeit kann man sagen, beim Umgangsspray.
Warten Sie, es kommt jetzt vom Alter?
Oder ist es ein anderer Grund dahinter?
Alter, ich glaube.
Ich bin aber noch Topfit, auch wenn ich 83 Jahre alt bin.
Gut, dann gucken wir mal nach.
Seit 82 Jahren schlagt Ihre Herz-Routine.
Dann ist das ein bisschen müde geworden.
Ich möchte noch ein bisschen leben, Herr Doktor.
Ich möchte noch ein bisschen.
Die 95 möchte ich noch erreichen.
Ich glaube auch, dass Sie mir das nicht glauben.
Gut, dann danke ich Ihnen für Ihre Zeit, Herr Doktor.
Ich danke Ihnen auch.
Ich habe einige Fragen.
Bitte schön, Herr Doktor.
Hat sich Ihre Geschichte in der Nähe seit März verändert?
Ich meine ja, ich hatte in den letzten 2-3 Wochen,
ich habe mich auf die Waage gestellt.
Das war schon so 3-4 kg mehr, obwohl ich nicht mehr gegessen habe.
Wie viel Kilogramm ungefähr?
Ja, so ungefähr 4 kg.
Dankeschön.
Haben Sie bemerkt, dass Ihre Beine gelötet oder warm sind?
Sie haben gesagt, Ihre Beine geschwollen?
Die sind schon sehr stark geschwollen.
Das spannt und es tut auch weh.
Aber Gerötete habe ich jetzt nichts gemerkt.
Wie viele Stufen können Sie steigen, bevor Sie Luft nach Hause kommen?
Vorher war ich früher Ruderer und war auch sehr sportlich.
Also bis vor einem Jahr konnte ich 3-4 Stockwerke ohne Pause hochsteigen.
Jetzt bin ich schon nach dem halben Stockwerk, also das sind vielleicht 10 Stufen,
muss ich nach Luft japsen.
Dankeschön.
Ich habe es heute nicht verraten können, aber ich habe es vergessen.
Noch andere Fragen, Kollegen?
Von den Kollegen.
Von Kolleginnen natürlich auch.
Haben Sie heute keine Wurst?
Haben Sie schon mal geraut?
Ja, ja, früher.
Ich habe gesagt, ich habe vor 30 Jahren damit aufgehört.
Wie viele Jahre haben Sie geraut?
Ich glaube, so fast 30 Jahre.
Wie viele Zigaretten haben Sie geraut?
Täglich.
Das war schon bis zu einer Schachtel am Tag.
Wir hatten einen stressigen Job.
Damals war es üblich, dass man geraucht hat.
Haben Sie Husten?
Husten?
Wenn ich mich hinlege, dann muss ich öfters husten, ja, aber so nicht.
Haben Sie auch sonst dabei?
Bitte?
Haben Sie Auswurf dabei?
Auswurf?
Nein, habe ich nicht mehr.
Gehen Sie in der Nacht oft zur Toilette?
Nein, nachts muss ich öfters.
Sagst du über nicht, aber nachts muss ich öfters zur Toilette.
Haben Sie Schmarschen beim Massalassen?
Nein.
Können Sie ausreichende Wasser trinken?
Ausreichend Wasser trinken, ja.
Ich komme ungefähr auf 1,5 bis 2 Liter am Tag.
Wie sieht es aus Ihrem Hahn?
Dunkel oder hell?
Das ist sehr unterschiedlich.
Ich würde es mal normal bezeichnen.
Es steht da jetzt keinen großen Unterschied.
Keine weiteren Fragen?
Ich denke keine.
Wir machen die Übergabe an den Oberarzt.
Herr Oberarzt, ich habe eine Patientaufgabe.
Eine Patientaufgabe.
Eine Patiententenaufgabe.
Ich würde Ihnen gerne vorstellen.
Was haben Sie da?
Eine 85-jährige Patient stellte sich mit Atemnot vor.
Mit Dusbne vor.
Zeit 2 Wochen.
Schlimmer geworden.
Was hat das?
Dusbne oder Belastungsdusbne?
Belastungsdusbne ist es.
Bevor hatte er 3-4 Stockwerke aufgetreten.
Jetzt können er nur 1,5 Stück aufgehen.
Er hat die Stoffe, die er hat, nicht auf den Treppen steigen.
Bevor die 3-Stoffwerke laufen, steigen.
Nur 1,5-Stoffwerk steigen.
Er habe die Odeone bei den Beinen.
Er hat 2-3 kg zugenommen.
Trotz der Erkrankung, er konnte nicht gut essen.
Er ist erschöpft.
Er fühlt immer müde.
Er fühlt sich müde.
Er fühlt der Erkrankung müde.
Er merkte Wasserlasten.
sind gestorben, aber sie hätten auch die gleichen Krankheiten.
Das ist meine erste Gespräche.
Ich weiß nicht, ob ich es gut machen kann.
Aber alles gut, alles gut.
Die machen das gut, Herr Dr.
Und beim
Im Liegen,
beim Legen habe er
mehrere Schwierigkeiten
beim Luftabnahme.
Also nicht beim Legen,
sondern beim Liegen.
Hat er verstärkte Luftnot?
Verstärkte Luftnot und er müsste
beim Schlafen
sich setzen.
Er kann nicht mehr liegen,
er muss im Sitzen schlafen.
Ja.
Er habe bemerkt, dass seine Halsbähne
vergrößert sind.
Und wie nennt sich das medizinisch?
Seine Jugularwähnen sind gestaut.
Welche Wähnen sind gestaut?
Jugularwähnen sind gestaut.
Ich glaube, er hat einen Herzinfizient.
Sie vermuten, als
ihre Verdachtdiagnose ist eine Herzinfizient.
Was meinen Sie, ist es eine
Linksherzinfizient oder eine Rechtsherzinfizient?
Rechtsherzinfizient ist,
denke ich, ein Rechtsherzinfizient.
Nein, links ist es.
Beides ist möglich, aber geschwollene Beine
sind gestaut.
Luftnot und Wasserfronten
sind linksherzinfizient.
Ja, ich denke, es ist eine Rechtsherzinfizient
und Luftnot und linksherzinfizient.
Machen Sie für eine Untersuchung, um das festzustellen,
was der Auslöser ist oder was die Ursache ist?
Eine EKG schreibe am Anfang,
das ist die wichtigste.
Und danach ein Eko auf dem Herz durchführen.
Sie führen ein Echo-Kardiogramm durch.
Das Herz wollen Sie nicht sagen.
Ein Echo-Kardiogramm ist ein Ultraschall vom Herz.
Sie führen ein Echo-Kardiogramm durch.
Ja.
Okay.
Und eine Blutabnahme ist wichtig.
Welche Laborwerte wollen Sie untersuchen?
Die Herz-Enzyme muss ich mal anschauen.
Vielleicht habe ich auch Hemoglobin-Abfall.
Was heißt Hemoglobin-Abfall medizinisch?
Eine Anämie.
Anämie, ja.
Anämie kann ich mehr haben.
Also Pulmoner-Emboli kann es sein.
Aber diese Beschwerden sind nicht plötzlich aufgetreten.
Nichtsdestotrotz kann das auch mal eine Lungenembolie sein.
Natürlich, was sich langsam entwickelt hat.
Ja, nur nicht für Lungenembolien kann es sein.
Gibt es eine Anamnese für eine Beinwähnentrompose?
Nein.
Er hat keine Rötung auf den Beinen.
An den Beinen?
Okay.
Also Sie denken, er hat keine Trompose gehabt.
Aber wir können kurz eine Ultraschalldorf führen.
Zu dem Wehnendoppler-Ultraschalldorf.
Macht ein Wehnendoppler sehr gut.
Und welchen Laborwert untersuchen Sie?
Die Neuermuster ist auch.
Die Untersuchung, die Mehrere.
Bei einer Herz-Enzymphyse, welchen Wert würden Sie dann noch mit untersuchen?
Also der Einwähler, der Tromponidin zum Ausstieg des Herz-Enfarktes.
Da fehlt mein, hatte Patient eine instabile AP?
Oder ist eine KHK bekannt?
Nee, KHK.
Er hat viel geraucht, aber ich glaube nicht, dass er KHK hat.
Also er hat in der Anamnese keine Herzerkrankungen gehabt?
Entschuldigung.
Ich habe es in der Koach-Unterstand.
KHK kann es auch sein.
KHK kann es sein.
Okay.
Koach ist der türkische Name.
COPD ist der deutsche Name.
COPD.
Okay.
Die Maschigkeit beim Begriff.
Genau.
Und welchen Wert?
Noch mal zu der Frage.
Welchen Laborwert untersuchen Sie bei einer Herz-Insuffizienz?
Was fällt Ihnen da hin?
Vorhin kam ein kleiner Tipp.
ProBMP kann es sein.
Genau.
Wir sagen das NT ProBMP.
Das ist ein Parameter, um die Herz-Insuffizienz ein bisschen abzuschätzen.
Wie hoch ab wann sprechen Sie von einer Herz-Insuffizienz?
Wie hoch muss diese Wert sein?
Wissen Sie das vielleicht noch?
Ich weiß nicht, wie wertvoll.
Was sagen die Kardiologen?
Wie hoch sollte ab wann spricht man von einer Herz-Insuffizienz?
Oder einer schweren Herz-Insuffizienz?
Herr Dr. Gündüst, wo ist der Kardiologe?
Wir sind nicht mehr da.
Was sagen die anderen Kollegen?
Also das NT ProBMP, das ist ein noch genauerer Wert.
Ab ein Wert von 600, 700 oder 800 ist das schon eine Herz-Insuffizienz.
Der normale Wert ist aber bei 300 bis 400.
Und meistens haben Patienten, die eine Herz-Insuffizienz haben,
Werte von 2, 3 oder 5.000.
Das spricht schon für eine ausgeprägte Herzschwäche.
Sehr gut Herr Doktor.
Was vermuten Sie, wenn Sie ein Herz-Echo durchführen, was der Patient hat?
Die rechts-Herzwand würde beide Herzwände vergrößert sein.
Ja, also vergrößert.
Ein erweitertes Herz.
Sie erwarten eine Herzschwäche und an den Herzklappen.
Welche Herzklappe könnte ein Problem sein?
Allein könnte Probleme haben.
Aber am meisten soll es beim Aorta und pulmenärklappen getroffen sein.
Und also mit Reinklappen kann es auch sein.
Mit Reinklappen wahrscheinlich, bei den älteren Herzschafen.
Vielleicht liegt eine mit Reinklappen insuffizienz.
Warum muss man schauen?
Das muss man schauen.
Wenn eine rechts-Herzbelastung hat,
ist die Trikospitalklappe auch erweitert.
Gut, das sehen wir alles im Herzultraschall.
Super.
Erhöhte pulmonär.
Pulmonär.
Okay, das kann.
Muss man schauen, ob eine rechts-Herzbelastung vorliegt.
Bei einer Trikospitalklappe insuffizienz oder bei einer vielleicht
vorbelastenden COPD, dass eine rechts-Herzinsuffizienz dauerhaft.
Kann natürlich auch sein.
Aber eine Lungenembolie macht auch eine rechts-Herzbelastung.
Führt zu einer pulmonalen Hypertonie.
Okay, muss man alles mal nachschauen.
Sehr gut.
Das heißt, Ihre Verdachtstärkmose,
die wir jetzt zusammenfassen, ist eine Herzinsuffizienz.
Was sind die Differenzialdiagnosen?
Woran müssen Sie noch denken?
Herzinfarkt haben Sie gesagt.
Lungenembolie haben Sie gesagt.
Rechts-Herz- oder links-Herzinsuffizienz haben Sie gesagt.
Woran denkt man auf?
Paraziten kann es sein, vielleicht.
Paraziten?
Ja.
Was ist das?
Ich weiß es nicht.
Paraziten denke ich weniger.
Denken Sie an eine Lungenproblematik?
Eine Pneumonie kann es auch sein.
Eine Pneumonie?
Okay.
Woran denkt man?
Herzinfarkt haben Sie gesagt.
Eine pulmonale Hypertonie, eine primäre pulmonale Hypertonie,
kann natürlich auch mal eine Ursache sein,
dass es eher von der Lunge aus geht
und dadurch auf dem zweiten Weg das Herz belastet.
Genau.
Leberzerose kann es mir vorstellen.
Kann natürlich auch sein, dass über die Leberzerose
eine Rechts-Herzinsuffizienz entsteht.
Das ist richtig.
Okay.
Hat jemand sonst noch eine Idee?
Denke ich, können wir heute langsam abschließen.
Sehr gut. Keine Fragen, keine Kritik.
Sehr gut.
Also, Herr Doktor, sehr gut.
Das war sehr gut, dass es das erste Mal ist.
Sie sind ein bisschen nervös und aufgeregt gewesen.
Sind Sie schon Facharzt, Herr Kollege?
Ich bin Facharzt.
Für allgemeine Chirurgie.
Für Schiffchen.
Okay. Für Missterachirurgie oder was machen Sie?
Allgemein alles.
Visceral habe ich auch ein bisschen gelehrt.
Sehr gut. Wo waren Sie? Sie sind auch aus der Türkei.
Ja.
Wo waren Sie in der Türkei?
In Ankara habe ich ein bisschen gearbeitet
und habe in Samsun meine Studie mitgekriegt.
Ah, sehr schön. Soll eine sehr schöne Stadt sein.
Ich war noch nie dort.
Karaman, erhielte ich nicht.
Bitte?
Ich habe auch eine Medaille in Karaman gemacht.
Ah, okay.
Sehr gut. Also, das war sehr gut.
Sie sind ein Chirurg und haben sich über internistische Erkrankungen
sehr gut ausgekannt.
Sie sind ein bisschen nervös.
Das ist gut. Das ist normal.
Wir haben ein bisschen mit der Grammatik, mit der deutschen Grammatik.
Das ist schwer natürlich, bevor das wird.
Und ich denke, Sie lernen das sehr, sehr schnell.
Das ist sehr gut.
Danke.